éisé après avoir passé ce sepéna dans le
Maqui de son opposition après avoir
adopté ces derniers temps une démarche
que l'on a comparé à celle de la tortue
monsieur bar en fin de matinée a donc
souhaité changer de vitesse à 3 mois
jour pour jour du second tour de
l'élection Raymond bar 63 ans s'est
lancé dans sa première campagne
présidentielle depuis sa ville de Lyon
une allocution de 4 minutes devant
l'ensemble de la presse
française mes chers
compatriotes depuis des
années je vous rencontre je vous écoute
je dialogue avec
vous un lien s'est créé entre
nous dans 3 mois vous choisirez un
nouveau
président vous le ferez dans une période
difficile vous voyez mal l'avenir vous
êtes dans le
doute le chômage continue à
frapper l'économie française plus
d'emploi c'est un
fait pendant le sepéna qui
s'achève la France a reculé par rapport
à ses
concurrents et pourtant les forces du
renouveau sont en
nous notre jeunesse est dynamique et
généreuse nos entreprises avec leurs
cadres leurs employés leurs ouvriers
s'ouvrent à la
internation nous sommes à la croisée des
chemins si votre choix devait conduire
au retour du système socialiste dont
vous ne pouvez oublier les erreurs ni
les
échecs après le recul viendrait le
déclin ne sous-estimez pas
l'en je ne me résigne pas pour ma au
déclin de mon pays il est temps de
mettre fin au faux semblant il est temps
de prendre un nouveau
départ c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé d'être
candidat à la présidence de la
République à l'origine de cette décision
il y a avant tout la confiance que
beaucoup d'entre vous me
témoignez vous me
connaissez comme tout le monde j'ai mes
qualités et mes
défauts mais je ne suis pas un
spécialiste de la
vieevolte je n'ai jamais fardé la
réalité j'ai toujours agi avec
loyauté je suis un homme
d'ouverture je n'ai pas l'esprit de
parti je veux un état
impartial au service de
tous
si vous m'accordez votre
confiance nous traiterons
ensemble les questions essentielles dont
dépend de notre avenir et l'avenir de
nos enfants la vitalité de la
famille la qualité de
l'éducation le renouveau de la recherche
de la
technologie le poids des
impôts la de la protection sociale le
drame
humain de la pauvreté et de la
solitude nous devons faire de la France
un pays solide à ce niveau de salaire et
d'emploi élevé à monnaie forte
ensemble nous travaillerons pour que
notre vieux pays de liberté renforce sa
cohésion par la solidarité par la
justice et qu'il retrouve le sens
profond du civisme et du patriotisme
ensemble nous ferons de la France
l'artisan d'une véritable union
économique monétaire et politique de
l'Europe à cet
instant je pense à mes rencontres avec
les Françaises et les Français de la
métropole de l'outremer et de
l'étranger je pense à mon île natale la
réunion je pense à cette ville d'où je
vous parle à Lyon qui m'a élu
m'adressante à chacune et à chacun
d'entre vous je
dis il est temps de faire confiance à la
France et au
français si vous le voulez ensemble nous
ferons une France forte et
fraternelle ayant choisi Lyon pour
annoncer en 4 minutes et 40 secondes sa
candidature